un premier coloc dédié à la
transformation des quartiers
prioritaires le département des Yvelines
l'a organisé ce jeudi 21 septembre sous
le Phénix de Chanteloup-les-Vignes et
pour en parler Catherine Arnoux bonjour
bonjour vous êtes maire justement de la
commune de Chanteloup-les-Vignes mais
aussi vice-présidente du conseil
départemental en charge de l'insertion
et de la rénovation urbaine sur les
quartiers politiques de la ville dans
les Yvelines il y en a 31 un quartier
prioritaire ce qui représente une
population de 157.000 habitants sujets
d'importance pourquoi tout simplement
lancer ce premier colloque pour
co-organiser cet événement ce jeudi 21
septembre à Chanteloup-les-Vignes
d'abord pour partager pour partager la
volonté politique du département depuis
2015 le département c'est lourdement
engagé je crois que c'est le seul
département de France qui a mis cette
volonté politique à accompagner les
quartiers prioritaires dans leur
transformation pas seulement ceux qui
avaient été retenus par l'État au titre
de l'agence de rénovation urbaine mais
aussi tous les quartiers qui étaient
déjà en politique de la ville et qui
avait montré déjà des fragilités
urbaines nous avons accomp donc dans un
premier mandat nous avons accompagné
13 quartiers prioritaires et puis nous
continuons notre volonté politique dans
ce deuxième mandat en étant attentif à
ces quartiers qui 60 quartiers
prioritaires soit en décrochage soit en
risque de décrochage parce que
l'intelligence de la politique c'est
d'arriver avant c'est de voir ce qui a
été le drame de nos quartiers
prioritaires depuis 40 ans et de savoir
donner aux collectivités aux élus aux
habitants les moyens de transformer
durablement leur quartier ce programme
c'est prioriveline et on parle pas que
de rénovation urbaine c'est un programme
un peu plus global pour pour ces
quartiers prioritaires alors le
département c'est a pris lourdement la
compétence politique de la ville ça
regroupe évidemment l'urbain parce que
là on va être beaucoup dans l'urbain
mais l'urbain qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
pour accompagner les habitants à mieux
vivre à avoir non seulement une qualité
de vie mais une qualité de service que
peuvent lui proposer les collectivités
locales mais qui ont besoin pour ça de
l'appui du département alors oui c'est
l'occasion aussi de penser la ville de
demain cette ville qui a été construite
dans des qui ont été construites
toujours dans des dans des conditions
extrêmement rapides qui évidemment ne
pensait pas du tout développement
durable il y a 40 ans ça n'était pas le
terme et qui pensait assez mal
l'insertion et l'inclusion donc on a
voulu et c'est ce qui est ce qui est ce
qui est aujourd'hui la les échanges
c'est en fait d'échanger d'abord sur ce
que fait le département les projets mais
aussi d'échanger nos compétences
d'échanger nos regards éventuellement de
dézoomer nos regards avec des
intervenants extérieurs qui nous qui
nous expliquent qui qui nous font
dézoomer repenser et puis c'est aussi
mettre l'accent sur cette petite
particularité des départements des
Yvelines qui dans son accompagnement à
la politique de la ville au
renouvellement urbain c'est donner une
vocation forte c'est la relation et la
vocation éducative et l'essentiel des
projets de renouvellement urbain des
Yvelines ce sont des projets qui sont
tournés autour de l'éducation
essentiellement autour de l'enfant aussi
aussi autour de la petite enfance et
puis aussi autour de cette ville
inclusive qui doit effectivement inclure
tous les habitants quartier on va
revenir sur le programme de ces tables
rondes vous avez parlé d'acteurs
justement pour vous accompagner durant
cette journée qui sont-ils on imagine
des experts sur la question de la
rénovation sur la question de des
quartiers prioritaires alors des experts
de notre territoire parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup des experts d'autres
territoires qui ont déjà un passé et une
lecture de la rénovation urbaine et puis
des experts qui regardent qui regardent
l'évolution de la société dans sa
globalité et on a pu justement
interroger quelques-uns de ces experts
qui étaient présents pour cette journée
du jeudi 21 septembre j'interviens sur
la thématique de l'urbanisme temporaire
transitoire et dans les cadres des
projets de renouvellement urbain
allons-rue considère que c'est une
opportunité pour améliorer la
transformation du cadre de vie des
habitants donc pour moi c'est très
intéressant c'est de valoriser ce sujet
là et de partager les acquis des
différents acteurs du renouvellement
urbain avec la communauté
professionnelle qui va être réunie
aujourd'hui on travaille depuis quelques
années avec le département des Yvelines
et récemment avec la ville de trappes et
c'était une bonne opportunité pour nous
de venir présenter le travail qu'on fait
depuis de nombreuses années avec le
département et la ville de Trappes sur
l'accessibilité et l'inclusion des
personnes en situation de fragilité deux
grandes façons de trouver des solutions
la première c'est soit on est essayé de
prendre le problème d'une autre façon de
d'aller faire des approfondissements des
nouvelles façons de de récolter des
données de cerner mieux le problème et
après essayer de concevoir des solutions
ça c'est la première grande façon et
l'autre façon c'est vraiment en
co-construisant la solution avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes il
faudrait essayer de trouver les
solutions tous ensemble avec nos angles
les mettre ensemble nos angles
d'analyses les mettre ensemble et
essayer vraiment à partir de là de se
mettre en synergie pour fabriquer une
solution un peu plus globale pour
l'enfant et non pas juste découper les
différentes séquences de vie de l'enfant
et donc ces experts ont pu animer ces
trois tables rondes Catherine Arnaud
alors on détailler un tout petit peu ce
qui s'est passé lors de cette journée du
21 septembre il a été question notamment
de la ville inclusive vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure de quoi s'agit-il
justement alors la ville inclusive c'est
comment on dans des
et qui doivent mettre autour de la table
beaucoup d'intervenants qui doivent
faire participer complètement les
habitants à l'évolution des quartiers et
ce sont des programmes très longs
pendant ce temps long qui n'est pas
toujours le temps de l'habitant il y a
des lieux qui en fait perdent leur
première vocation parce qu'ils ont été
par exemple vidés de leur premier
vocation parce qu'ils ont ils vont être
ils vont être démolis et puis et puis il
y a des lieux qui vont qui vont se
transformer et avant leur état ultime
avant le moment où ils auront
effectivement la vocation qu'on leur a
donné au long terme on n'imagine pas
qu'il se puisse être détend mort avec
des lieux vides et comment penser ce
temps intermédiaire à la fois pour créer
des actions pour créer des d'autres
idées actions qui vont en fait nourrir
le programme à venir aussi donc voilà
c'est le temps intermédiaire qui est un
temps qui est trop long pour les
habitants et dans laquelle on a décidé
de donner du corps et la dernière table
ronde c'était donc transformée ces
quartiers aussi en transformant l'offre
éducative d'éducation aussi sur
Chanteloup-les-Vignes vous a été entre
guillemets précurseur puisque il y a ce
nouveau dispositif les cités éducatives
une des premières dans les Yvelines si
ce n'est même la première a été lancée
du côté de Chanteloup-les-Vignes c'est
la cité éducative Simone Veil
l'éducation c'est vous l'avez dit aussi
tout à l'heure une une part importante
une partie importante pour aussi œuvrer
la transformation de ces quartiers
l'éducation c'est d'abord la certitude
d'accompagner nos enfants pour devenir
des hommes et des femmes qui prennent
place dans la société l'éducation c'est
aussi remettre le parent au cœur de ce
dispositif qui n'est plus seulement le
dispositif de l'enseignement l'éducation
c'est aussi ce que regarde un parent qui
arrive sur un territoire comment mon
enfant va pouvoir être entouré
accompagné et donc le lieu le bâti les
projets qui sont autour de l'éducatif
sont le centre de l'évolution de nos
collectivités locales et un peu plus
dans ces quartiers
dernière question on l'imagine viendra
après un bilan de cette journée
d'échange autour de la question des
quartiers politiques de la ville est-ce
que ça pourra nourrir peut-être un futur
travail départemental qui est déjà
enclenché mais est-ce que ça pourra
servir nourrir votre réflexion alors
bien sûr mais pas seulement la l'idée et
la pensée du conseil départemental
l'idée c'est aussi que les partenaires
eux-mêmes se nourrissent de ces travaux
en commun à la fois des des projets que
portent le département de l'ambition
qu'il y met mais on sait très bien que
l'ambition elle doit se décliner au
niveau local et elle doit se décliner
par les élus par les habitants par les
partenaires par les éducateurs enfin par
tout le monde et je pense que il y aura
d'autres métamorphoses
urbaines merci Catherine Arnaud mère de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes vice-présidente du
conseil départemental en charge de
l'insertion et de la rénovation urbaine
c'est la fin du 7 8 merci de nous avoir
suivi très belle soirée sur TV 78